wiggles a year old pup from California
was rescued from the street by animal
control they noticed immediately
something was wrong
wriggles falls frequently and can't
control his bowels at a local shelter
these unusual symptoms put his chances
for adoption near zero but here at dog
town they consider every animal
adoptable now the challenge for the team
find the right home for this disabled
dog hey Wiggles boy at dog towns clinic
head veterinarian dr. Mike Dix evaluates
Wiggles for the first time he must
determine if Wiggles suffers from a
life-threatening illness or if his
condition is manageable good boy that's
watch your walk
he's like a drunken sailor first
impression of Wiggles is is crazy it's
cute and an ugly sort of way and he's
just very endearing Wiggles symptoms may
be the result of bad breeding technique
he was found somewhere near like a
bulldog breeder which he kind of does
have Bulldog qualities with his short
squatty legs as under biased service
question phase dog breeders often use
inbreeding to guarantee desirable traits
but this technique limits the gene pool
and can lead to genetic mutations with
symptoms like the ones Wiggles displays
it could be a purebred dog purebred gone
awry
who knows dr. Mike's first goal
determined Wiggles condition is
neurological
he puts Wiggles through a battery of
diagnostic tests and so most dogs when
you flip it over would return to normal
right away there's not a sigh - should
have righted it quicker
Mike discovers a disconnect between the
nerves and Wiggles foot in his brain
indicating a problem with his
neurological system whether that's a
problem with the brain problem with the
nerves or problem with the pathway as
well we don't know gonna be something
going on with a cerebellum the
cerebellum the part of the brain which
controls balance plays a vital role in
basic motor function my men assume I'm
sure I kind of pretend like I'm gonna
poke him in the eye he's blinking quite
a bit
yes you need a cerebellum intact to do
that
Wiggles blink response indicates a
normal cerebellum Jacobo why a dog like
Wiggles it's actually kind of an
exciting interesting case I figure out
where his problem is
I've always been kind of science minded
person wondering how things work how to
fix things the little intricate
processes that are involved in life a
malformed spine might explain Wiggles
symptoms an x-ray will reveal that this
is the problem
I just my handsome
this spine actually looks pretty good
doesn't mean it's not a spinal issue but
there's nothing obvious with a severe
brain or spinal injury ruled out it's
likely Wiggles was born with a genetic
defect that affects his neurological
system but he's stable
so Mike gives the go-ahead for adoption
I think what he has is gonna be a
permanent issue with him but the goal
will be that he can learn to cope with
what he has and adjust accordingly
now Dogtown faces a daunting task find a
family willing to care for Wiggins
disabilities at all finding a home for a
squatty bulldog ish dog that falls over
and occasionally drops poop it's just a
little bit harder to find the right
person for them just takes a little more
time